molly norris mais pas
j'y vais c'est
détective privé et tout voir
alors quand le fbi a ya besoin d'un
agent infiltré et moi une fille qui va à
la fac on voudrait que vous gardiez un
oeil sur elle molly est la seule à
pouvoir remplir la mission n'y a
personne au fbi qui peut faire des 100
kg est longue des moustaches tôt ce même
les femmes va falloir quitter ce
déguisement c'est très négligée on
dirait qu un teckel dépressif est venu
suicider sur sa tête je vous ferai
remarquer que je vous entends je suis
trop il n'a filtré si elle arrive à se
faire passer pour une étudiante situé
broughton briques
comment ça va et à se faire accepter par
toutes ces soit 7 factor et pourquoi tu
dis ça j'ai 18 ans je suis sur le campus
porte un nom de bourges cher mobile qui
brille pourra veiller
faites attention sur la fille du témoin
alex tu te souviens pas de moi dit
défaisant le chalet numéro neuf et je
vous fais défoncer clé aller au camp
waka waka but a vu ce qui arriva chez
les seniors peuvent rester fantastique
on a dû lui couper le bras levé ce
qu'elle fait avec son autre bras s'y
trouve hallucinant campus marche est
peut-être une source d'android avec une
âme
ces infos sérieux videmment tu connais
une urne dans la sphère lundi je vais te
coller une prune dans la phase 6 trop
bizarre et c'est pas bizarre de se
coller une burne dans la tronche deux
grosses embrouilles
non ça c'est un truc de détraqués à bout
pour écouter une tête dans la piscine
pressurant va s'éclater
c'est pas là pour m'éclater les trucs
que je devrais d'avoir alors une super
crew spengler oui j'en veux une moi
aussi et toi vous 1,6 milliard modèle
1911 avec un grand avenir en v et un
flingue style mais p 226 avec une crosse
en nacre et une grosse bentley